[Musique]
ambiance des grands soirs au Vélodrome
national après Mayork et Berlin l'UCI
track Champions League a fait étape à 50
ans en Eveline pour la 3è manche
quelques grands noms du cyclisme sur
piste féminin et masculin s'affrontait
sur quatre épreuves du sprint et de
l'endurance le tout pendant une soirée
l'objectif pour les organisateurs offrir
du spectacle au public réinventer la
manière dont on présente le cyclisme sur
piste au public en essayant de le
simplifier au maximum et de le rendre de
plus en plus spectaculaire à quelques
mois des GI la ferveur olympique s'est
ressentie dans les gradins cinquantinois
près de 3900 spectateurs ont assisté à
la compétition au Vélodrome site de
paris 2024 la Fluence a presque doublé
par rapport à l'édition de l'année
dernière pour les Jos ça m'a semblé
compliqué de venir donc j'ai profité de
cette réunion pour venir là moi j'aime
beaucoup ce type de format parce que
c'est un vrai spectacle et il y a une
vraie compétition on fait de la piste
aussi à SaintQuentin donc voir les les
pro rouler beaucoup plus que nous c'est
c'est plutôt cool aussi côté français
pas de Marie divine Kamet ni de Mathilde
gros vainqueur de la Champions League
l'an passé trois bleus étaient engagés
sans obtenir de résultats probants
devant leur public quandtin lafar
termine dernier du scratch et 13e de la
course par élimination le champion du
monde 2019 du kilomètre a commencé
depuis peu sa mutation de la vitesse
vers les épreuves d'endurance je suis
venu parce que parce que je trouvais ça
intéressant je me suis dit que dans dans
l'idée ça allait animer un peu ma prép
hivernal et que ça allait pouvoir me
faire faire des des efforts en
compétition qui étaient plus agréaable
plus décevant en revanche pour les
Français engagé dans les épreuves de
vitesse melvin landerno et Tom de rche
ont été éliminés dès le premier tour du
sprint et du Kerin un peu déçu forcément
parce que on veut toujours faire mieux
devant devant devant son public mais je
sais je sais que je travaille beaucoup
en ce moment donc je peux pas non plus
espérer travailler fort la semaine et
être fort le le le le weekend l'objectif
c'est voilà courir prendre de
l'expérience faire aussi plaisir c'est
un peu dur forcément quand se fait
sortir mais il faut garder ça en tête
pour les prochains matchs au classement
général du sprint dominé par le
néerlandais la vraie scène Tom de rche
perd sa 3e place il compte désormais 16
points de retard sur le podium l'UCI
track Champions League s'achève les 10
et 11 novembre prochains deux dernières
étapes au programme à Londres